Okay,
last time.
Okay.
Everybody piped down.
So last time we discussed two factors that limited,
uh,
that retarded and limited your progress.
Remember I,
I'm describing that Europe was in a pretty bad situation.
Uh,
one was sort of mental,
cultural.
There was a mindset that largely focused on the supernatural and did not have
that mindset to question received wisdom and to test whatever they believed
against what they saw in reality.
The second was of food and population balance that left vast numbers of people
in conditions of near starvation.
Around 1750 rounds,
1700 Europe started to outgrow these limitations.
And we started talking about that last time we saw how the scientific revolution
given great impetus by Newton.
He wasn't the only one,
but the hit the fabulous success in,
in explaining the universe that Newton's three very simple laws.
We learned that certainly in high school,
if not in junior high school,
uh,
explain how all the heavens work.
And that was an amazing,
uh,
creation of the human mind and had tremendous import and started,
what's been called,
uh,
the enlite,
the enlightenment.
So that that's sort of sea change,
the mental set and into something more progressive.
And then as you've read in,
I hope in your course packet,
the introduction of foods from America sort of cut down,
uh,
got rid of the physical limitation on,
on,
uh,
population and economic wellbeing in Europe that the amount of food went way up.
And so this,
especially the food increased the European population.
There's all kinds of different numbers available,
but,
uh,
anywhere from 62% up to a doubling of the European population due to the
introduction of,
of European foods.
Now the standard belief about population and fat time is that population is a
wonderful thing.
And,
uh,
John Jacques Rousseau,
who we've talked about who was abandoning his own children by the Carload to
control his individual families,
the number of children they had to cope with.
Uh,
in terms when he thought about the grand,
the,
the political system,
he said that government under which the citizens do most increase and multiply
is infallibly the best.
Similarly,
the government under which your people diminish as a number and wastes away is
the worst.
And so he's very clear that not only is high population good,
but it's infallibly good.
Benjamin Franklin,
around 1751 argued about this.
There were upwards of 1 million English soles in America is before the
revolution,
the mill,
this million doubling suppose,
but once in 25 years,
which is not a bad estimate of the doubling time of American population at that
time,
do largely due to immigration doubling once every 25 years within and another
will in another century be more than the people of England.
What an expression of power that will be.
And the realization of American increase in numbers and therefore increase in
power was very important in the history of that time after the French and Indian
war before our revolution,
that you know of the settlement,
that the English got.
Canada and the friend,
which was barren,
wasn't worth very much at the time.
And the French kept the islands in the Atlantic,
which were very rich,
sugar and plantations slavery of course.
Uh,
the French kept those and the English took Canada.
Why?
To keep the Americans in check because they knew that the Americans would get,
uh,
get very strong.
Thomas Jefferson often said population is power.
So in 1800,
when the U S is only 10 years old,
so very fragile in terms of our,
our,
our strength,
our military strength and everything like that.
Napoleon had recently a Spain had owned Louisiana,
which was the whole vast territory to the west of of the 13 colonies and during
the Napoleonic wars and Napoleon,
uh,
got charge of them.
And so he was going to send a French troops there to occupy Louisiana because
they were such a big and important territory.
But the US of course objected.
We were having this huge population growth,
immigration,
they were flooding over the Appalachian mountains into the territories and the
next boundary with the Mississippi River.
And America did not want any of the European powers are taking control there.
The French ambassador in stay in America realized that America was growing so
rapidly and empower knee,
foot and Napoleon site he did send troops were stupid,
but at no point would lose the war.
So this guy was very clever.
He did one thing,
he sent him Napoleon,
a summary of the American census of 1800 [inaudible] remember that in the
constitution we have to take a census.
It was one taken in 1800 and it showed such a great rate of American population
increase that that's all he had to send.
It showed that the u s population was doubling every 22 years,
not the 25 that Benjamin Franklin had estimated.
Napoleon got the message immediately.
There was no way that France was going to be able to hold Louisiana,
uh,
against American objections.
So what of Napoleon do
sold it?
Sold it to us for a pittance.
Basically a Petten's cause he knew he could not hold it.
The power of population.
Now why did governments love large populations?
Why was it power?
Two things.
One,
a lot of men.
And what do you do with men?
Take him into the army.
So you have big military power also more people,
far more land,
produce more food and other goods.
And then what can you do?
You can tax it.
So the governments get a lot of tax and a lot of people if they have a big
population.
So,
uh,
it was sort of no question in anyone's mind that,
that are,
uh,
on a big and growing population was just a wonderful sort of thing.
What they didn't realize is one of the things that I'm trying to get across in
this class,
that that system works,
uh,
for a situation where you have no limitation on land or resources.
It's like I've been,
I was describing for Africa where the population was small and land was large,
then population is,
can be a benefit in the way just described.
But the reality for Europe especially was different.
Uh,
after 1750,
again,
largely due to the American foods,
uh,
people filled the European countrysides to overflowing capacity.
This,
these are quotes from him from various sources.
Back then mountain spilled over with people.
Cities grew and the plane's became full.
But this increase in population brought more mouths to feed population rose and
the resources could not match the population.
So when you have more consumers than goods.
So law of supply and demand prices,
rose people couldn't afford what they previously could afford and poverty
deepened.
So in this period in Europe,
people often move,
migrated seasonally to get jobs because they didn't have enough income from
their own land.
They would go to where some harvest,
they were needed to harvest or needed to work on a building project.
But at this time,
this population and people wandering around looking for some sort of work,
uh,
increased so much that the line between migration and vagabonds [inaudible]
becoming just a vagabond,
uh,
was crossed by hundreds of thousands of Europeans that were just wandering
around looking for some kind of work to keep them alive for a little bit longer.
And this was written,
noticed and written about a lot at the time.
Uh,
they flooded the highways roads we're opening up at the time they,
they flooded the highways of France,
Germany,
the countries,
all of these places.
This was noticed children at the time.
Again,
you read this crowded orphanages and founding homes,
women and children,
very large number of beggars arose at this time.
Women and children begged on church steps,
roadsides.
Uh,
this problem of poverty,
as I've mentioned,
was uh,
much observed,
much worried about,
much comment to the pond.
And in fact,
all of the,
the great intellectuals of the day whose names we still know,
commented upon it,
you'll know Edward Gibbon given,
wrote the
decline and fall of the Roman Empire,
one of the most famous peep intellectuals of that time right after that he wrote
in the civilized world,
the most numerous class is condemned to ignorance and poverty.
Why were people poor?
Well,
the general consideration then they were poor because they were in some way
deficient.
And the idea was that God had given some people,
kings and aristocrats,
the abilities and the capability to rule and all the others were relegated to
the lower classes.
They just didn't,
they had bad heredity.
They were lazy,
they were quoting the wrong sort.
They were inherently incapable that they're there.
Nature or human nature,
they didn't really have a genetic ideas back then was to be incapable of leading
the good kind of life.
Well,
this was a nice theory.
And,
and,
and the people who are upper class enough to get an education right about it,
could live comfortably with that theory.
But then America opens up for colonization and guess what happens?
Who moves to America,
the poorest people,
especially from England,
right?
The lower classes and moved to Australia,
isn't it late somewhat later time.
And then they empty out.
The prison's going to Australia's have really the lower classes.
And what happens to America as,
as I've just showed you,
the people work hard,
they're industrious,
they make a lot of money,
they get ahead,
everything looks very good in America.
And so the theory just didn't fit observation.
And as I've mentioned,
people are by now paying attention to what's around them.
And this idea that Americans had been so poor in England but they moved to
America and things get better.
So the question arose,
why would the poor so poor in England?
You know,
kind of an obvious question.
And again,
not the first time that this question had been asked.
The Bible,
and again,
I,
I sorry for keep referring to religion,
but you cannot just cannot discuss western intellectual history without,
without going that cause that was the basis of the way people thought.
So,
uh,
what the Bible says,
Ecclesiastes these,
when goods increase they are increased that eat then.
So as you,
if you have more stuff,
population grows and they eat the food very close to what we'll see.
Martha's uh,
says later,
Edmund Burke,
who is now considered the father of conservative political philosophy.
The laboring people are only poor because they are numerous numbers in their
nature imply poverty in a fair distribution.
But liberals who say no eat share equally in a fair distribution among a vast
multitude,
none can have much.
So he was talking against spreading the wealth because under that condition,
if you spread the wealth,
everybody is extremely poor.
So those kinds of thoughts started people thinking about the relationship
between population and resources.
What,
what was that?
This is sort of a fairly new way of thinking about things.
And where do they turn to?
Again,
in the spirit of the enlightenment,
science was the leading source of intellectual,
uh,
new ideas and natural history was going on.
Who was getting going at that time studying of plants and animals in their
natural habitats,
just like all your ta for this course.
And so Adam Smith,
among others,
pay great attention to what the naturalists were saying in the wealth of
nations.
1776,
every species of animal naturally multiplies in proportion to the means of their
subs.
Subsistence and no species can ever multiply beyond it.
And then he exploded,
says,
ma'am,
like all other animals naturally multiply in proportion to their means of
subsistence fisheries immediately applying an ecological law from the study of
animals to people.
Well,
how fast can humans multiply?
David Hume,
uh,
another one of the luminous philosopher,
1742,
almost every man who thinks he can maintain a family will have one.
And the human species at this rate of propagation would more than double every
generation.
Adam Smith again,
got some of the problem.
He realized that,
uh,
in,
in if wages increased,
if,
if things started to get better and wages increased,
uh,
this would lead to an increase in population.
He explicitly says if people have more money,
they're going to be able to feed their children more and they will stay alive
and,
uh,
there will be a decline in mortality and the population will grow.
But he so very surprised it did not close the circle and did not never
apparently realize that this growth in the population would be more competitors
for the jobs and would push,
uh,
wages back down again.
So that was the great achievement of office and all this interest in what is the
cause of poverty.
Uh,
and there are many other things.
There was an enclosure movement in England at the time where the lands on which
the peasants had lived were being closed in and controlled by the,
uh,
by the,
the,
uh,
squire is the country squires.
And so with a lot of other things going on,
but this was the kind of argumentation that was going on at the time.
So more office was the one that realized that population and wages and
mortality,
we're in a negative,
what we now call a negative feedback loop,
that if late wages increased,
as I've just said,
then population grows and a population grows.
The competition for jobs and for food and for everything else pushes wages back
down or pushes prices back up.
So if you earn the same,
you're still getting less.
So in short,
although the population could grow and the economy on a gross scale,
the there could grow the per capita income he basically said could not grow.
And so in the strongest in the strongest statement of this,
and he went through many additions with many different,
uh,
statements from the strongest statement.
Economic progress is basically impossible looked at from the point of view of
per capita income,
the living standards of the average person.
Most of the very clever and thought more deeply about it.
And he was aware of two contradictory changes that were happening throughout the
18th century.
He's right,
he writes to 1798 at the end of the 18th century,
as I've mentioned.
And you've read,
there's no question that agriculture was improving,
not only American foods,
uh,
but also,
agronomy was coming in as a science and people were learning even with the same
crops to improve the crops,
to improve their livestock,
to fertilize better,
to rotate fields better.
They were learning,
uh,
to,
to grow more,
more food.
And so nevertheless,
even though there was more food around poverty was growing and that was also
very clear at the time.
And so he,
he,
his argument is based on a few very simple kinds of statements,
uh,
contrary to some previous thinkers who in envisioned other later in population
and resources as there's a fixed amount of resources that there's a pie.
We now use the expression pie,
this pie.
And depending on how many people there are,
you divide the pie into smaller and smaller slices.
The more people,
the smaller slices of the pie,
that is completely wrong and never has been correct.
All people do some,
uh,
kind,
kind of work and in the pie grows with each person.
Some the pie grows to a certain degree.
And the question is how,
how much does the pie grow?
So for instance,
again in the United States,
the time we've had these vast lands to the west,
we were killing or had killed the Indians and they were very few of them anyway.
So that allowed each new person.
So as population grows,
again,
when you have no limitation of resources,
a new family is living on the frontier,
the frontier becomes crowded.
American population was growing very fast.
They were having lots of kids,
lots of immigrants where the new people go to,
they just move some miles to the west and they got a beautiful new farm and the
land is just as good as what was left behind.
And they grow as much as the PR as are farmers that they left behind.
So the population increases,
the gross economy increases,
and the per capita standard of living does not decrease because this guy has the
same amount of resources as the previous generation hat.
But this was not the condition in Europe
or in England or the rest of actual all across Eurasia.
Here,
the law of diminishing returns take effect because land starts to be limiting.
When land is limiting,
people are naturally smart.
What do they do with this beautiful land,
fertile land by a river?
Of course,
they farm that first,
right?
And so as population grows,
that gets taken up,
all the good land comes under the plow and as good population keeps growing,
well the next set of people have to go to more or less good land,
maybe dry or land,
maybe hillier or land.
And their productivity is not quite as good as the previous group that got the
best land.
Population keeps growing and people have to move,
um,
high on the mountain tops into dry areas and to desert areas and to swampy areas
in all kinds of areas where their production is not going to be as high.
So the average income from say farming,
uh,
decreases as you use less good land.
And so things conditions get worse.
And finally,
all the land is used up and there's no land for farmers whatsoever.
So this is the law of diminishing returns.
And if you're travel around,
uh,
you can really see the law of diminishing returns happen or a mix of how people
always do some work.
But when there isn't much resource to take advantage of,
uh,
they can accomplish very little.
So,
uh,
quite a few years ago I was traveling in the highlands of,
of Livia and Peru and a lot of native Indian markets,
they're very colorful,
you know,
tourists love to go to them,
but you watched the,
the ladies sit down and have a blanket in front of them and they display their,
their,
their wares and they had totally agricultural and they'll have maybe a,
a few fruits and a little bit of this and a little bit of that.
And they have,
you know,
almost nothing,
almost no stock on the blanket.
So they've grown this over the past six months or something.
They've walked all the way,
maybe even days to get to a market.
And then they have very little to sell.
And even if they could sell everything that they brought at some sort of a
profit,
they didn't have enough there.
The total amount that they would take home was still very,
very little,
but they were producing some,
but not very much.
Uh,
in the cities.
I've tell you one story.
So I was in,
in Lima improve this same trip and a lot of street vendors doing,
doing stuff.
And I saw one guy had a pair of socks up there and he had some sort of a,
a knitting needle or something like is holding up the sock.
And as he was talking to the crowd,
chatting,
the socket is knitting needle and he's saying,
you can't destroy this hockey.
Can't just try this.
I get to last the rest of your life,
bash,
patch.
And I'm watching him for awhile and I'm skeptical,
you know.
But [inaudible] seemed okay.
So the poor guy,
I bought the pair of socks,
that socks,
you couldn't,
I could not destroy them.
I used them for about 20 years.
So it was really true.
So he was,
you know,
making some sort of a meager living,
but it wasn't good.
If he had better jobs,
if there were more resources that he could utilize,
uh,
his low wages would not drag down the average.
And you must realize,
of course,
that when one says a phrase like that,
that he could,
there were resources that he could utilize,
brings up a vast consideration of power and everything else,
you know,
what are the resources and who gets to utilize them.
And so what,
so to it's a much more,
you know,
and of course is say a little bit and as much,
much more to say about all of these things.
So,
uh,
the,
the law of diminishing returns,
uh,
reduces,
the average productivity,
but then there's a countervailing trend,
which he also was aware of that I've just mentioned,
that the productivity of the land was increasing again,
through the new foods and new agricultural,
uh,
technologies.
And these two factors work in opposite directions and more office had to make
some sort of a guess as to how these two factors would balance out,
which would predominate.
Would the introduction of new technology improve faster than the law of
diminishing returns?
Uh,
decreased it.
And his conclusion was that technology would be somewhat stronger than the law
of diminishing returns.
So that total productive per capita productivity and total productivity would
indeed keep increasing,
but he thought it would increase sort of at a constant sort of a,
of a rate and in graphs terminals.
Let's see if I can get right to this graph.
So here is,
you'll see the rest of it.
This is the standard kind of guff about mall office.
Here is the way he thought that resources mostly uh,
food in his,
in the case at the time he was talking about,
he thought they would increase in the more or less a regular way per every year.
If you consider these years,
every year would increase by about the same amount he called that an arithmetic
growth.
We now call it a linear growth.
Um,
but he and everyone else knew that population can grow faster than that.
So you probably understand a little bit about exponential growth of each couple
has four surviving children,
not unreasonable.
And when there's a,
when there's a moderate amount of food and then these children have foreign.
So on.
The population does not grow for six eight 10 12 linear kind of thing.
It grows four eight 1632 64 you're used to counting this way from bits that's
called exponential growth where each generation a doubles or improves by some
percentage.
I've just made this graph at growing 10% a year and no matter where you stand
and the growth is like that,
that's an exponential curve and all exponential curves look,
look,
look like that.
You can change your scales,
but they all look exactly like that and it doesn't matter where you start,
you can start uh,
in England where these two curves would be pretty much matched at the time
Martha was writing.
Or you can start in America where resources are way above population at the
beginning,
but then you just wait.
America's starts filling up more and more rapidly.
As the population grows,
10% of a large population adds more people in a year,
then 10% of the small population.
So as time goes on the increment per year,
it gets bigger and bigger and eventually it outruns a resource growth.
So this is Martha's is mathematical formulation of his ideas and he believed it
to be an inevitability that this was an iron law of economics and that you
couldn't avoid this.
And so human population was doomed to per capita misery kind of thing.
And
he put it in this particular mathematical form.
But as you can see,
the mathematical form doesn't really matter as long as population can grow
faster than resources,
you're eventually going to get into this situation.
Even if population goes linearly,
if it grows at a faster pace than resources,
you're back into this situation.
So the idea,
the simple idea is that population can grow faster than resources.
And I think that's for sure.
True.
So Martha's was,
was,
uh,
certainly,
partly correct.
He was right and he was also wrong.
And he has been,
you've probably heard most of this always gets discussed,
you know,
since he wrote it.
Now,
big subject of controversy and I think the current sort of fashion is to,
is to put them down.
How many,
how many people have heard discussions of morphus and in how many does he come
out?
Well.
Yeah.
How many does it come out badly?
Well,
it's about split.
Okay.
Yeah,
in certain kinds of circles.
Uh,
it's very,
it's unfashionable to be a Malthusian and nowadays,
so he was right and he was wrong.
And what was he right about first he had apparently,
although the historians argue about this quite an accurate description,
this Malthusian situation is an accurate description of Europe from say about
1200 to almost until into the 17 hundreds.
So for about 500 years,
a very strong arguments can be made with whatever data is available that Europe
was in this Malthusian trap.
It also is,
I'll as I'll show you in a minute,
that as the industrial revolution took hold,
he was still right for almost another century and then things changed and he
didn't have this,
he had a crystal ball,
he was pretty good,
but he didn't have a real modern model,
crystal ball.
So there are two things that he did not
foresee.
He lived at the very beginning,
very beginning of the industrial revolution and didn't really realize its power.
So when he saw it,
he thought production of all sorts,
not only agriculture would increase kind of linearly,
that constant,
constant increments every year.
But in fact the way it has turned out is that not only can population increase
exponentially,
but production can increase exponentially.
And for the same reason basically that when you produce,
if you're in this scientific,
this
post enlightenment era where we know science makes life better,
um,
then as your economy increases,
you have more money and you devote a certain fraction of it to research,
to a technology.
And so as your economy grows every year,
you put more and more money into research.
So in the same way that if it's a percentage of your total income,
total national income or something that you invest and you get a good product
out of it,
then just like population every year you will have more income,
more gross national product,
more when you invest a certain fraction that you have more.
And also technology and science grows exponentially.
So what happened,
uh,
is that eventually,
technology grew production just as fast as population and in fact somewhat
faster than population.
So we sort of realize that when we say that our economy grows like 2% a year,
we don't say,
we sometimes say it grew by a million,
$100 million a year,
something like that.
But more often,
which is a linear statement,
100 million,
a hundred million,
hundred million,
but he just say 2%.
The next year you have 2% of 102% and the next year or 2% of 104%,
it grows faster and faster.
And again,
this kind of percentage increase in,
uh,
technology and production has exactly the same limit as population.
That there must be no external limits,
no resources,
uh,
that are limiting.
And now of course,
we realize we do have to worry about,
uh,
the limits of the environment.
And people have multiplied.
People have basically filled up the earth.
And,
uh,
the reason we're using everything that looks like we're using virtually
everything that humans can use and there's not much left.
So the question is,
you know,
can we continue to increase our production tingling?
And we don't know the answer to it.
Second thing that Moses didn't foresee was a big drop in the birth rate.
And uh,
he again acting sort of as a,
in the Newtonian mode of pronouncing scientific laws that were in viable and
inevitable.
He said the sex drive was an instinct.
People liked sex
and that would not go away.
So they would keep reproducing.
Now he was also aware of contraception.
People were doing various things even at that time.
And it was certainly an awareness,
but he was so,
he was a minister.
He was so morally opposed to that that he just would not really consider that
people would ever do that.
Uh,
so he,
he dismissed that kind of idea.
So what,
what happened that in some sense makes him wrong,
is that after about another hundred years after he writes,
production increases enough to keep up with population and the birth rate starts
dropping.
And we're going to talk about,
uh,
both two days.
Those,
both of those things,
when you think about Martha is going into these discussions that this strict
formulation of his ideas that,
you know,
does,
we can't make any economic progress and disasters eminent.
That's clearly not the case.
But if you just slightly rephrase,
uh,
his,
questions and ask not whether you have a dead stop to population growth,
to,
uh,
economic growth,
but they're in those countries and those places with very dense populations,
even though economic growth is,
is present there,
would the people be better off with a less,
a lesser population is more,
right?
Not In the extreme,
but in the,
in the reality that you can,
even in very dense populations,
you can have some economic growth.
But would the people be better off if they had less,
uh,
a lower population?
And then instead of asking the other amount of care,
instead of asking where the food is,
your limiting factor,
uh,
asking whether the environment is your limiting factor and that,
with those rather small changes in,
in,
in what he said,
uh,
makes Martha's as relevant today as,
as at any time.
So,
all right,
so let's look at some of the things that,
that,
that I've been talking about.
Uh,
this,
I think I could.
So you've all seen that you've seen this graph before,
and remember this is for Roman times,
but characteristic up too from way,
way back into almost into the 17 hundreds and a thousand females are born,
not very different for males.
Most of them die about half of them die as infants than childbirth and they keep
dying.
And eventually there's very few left.
This is the,
this is the number that are born and the number that are left.
So the reason I show this again is because there's one number here that I didn't
describe before,
but it's one way of characterizing this easier row is easiest,
is for the expectancy of life.
How long you're gonna live at age zero at your birth.
You know,
when a child is born,
how long do you expect them to live?
Of course that may be,
say 70 years old nowadays,
but my mother for instance,
is 97.
And so her life expectancy is like 102.
So the life expectancy depends on when you're measuring it.
And so this is life expectancy at birth.
And at this time it was just under 21 years of age.
And we've seen,
uh,
here that
when the live,
the,
the death rate is such to have this kind of a life expectancy,
that's something like a third of the women are doing all the reproducing because
the others are dead.
And if it's a third,
they have to have a six children to keep the population going.
But since a lot of that third,
uh,
is infertile or sick or unmarried or whatever,
the average has to be six.
The women who actually can reproduce,
have to produce a lot more.
And it turns out that,
uh,
that's about the limit that much with,
with the expectancy of life,
uh,
of much less than that,
much less than 20 or you maybe get it down to 20,
uh,
your,
your group,
your population goes extinct.
So think,
think mathematically,
just a little bit that if the average lifespan is 20 years,
then every one of those 20 years in equal number,
every,
every year,
one 20th of the population is going to die.
And one 20th is 5%.
So you can think of of 5%,
uh,
death rate as sort of the,
the maximum death,
5% of the population dies every year.
It's kind of a maximum that humans Khasis can sustain more than that.
And you have a lower,
a lower easy arrow,
your population goes out of existence.
Uh,
as time goes on,
I've shown you this slide.
Also,
conditions get a little better.
So here is the way this graph,
this is rather stylized.
We don't have great data to make such a con and graph,
but this shows the life expectancy.
But to train 20 and 25 years,
which we think is more or less the,
the,
the characteristic of humans for a long time.
And then very slowly over thousands of years it gets better.
And up here you may be at 25%.
So at 20,
I'm sorry,
25 years,
so 25 years.
If people are going to live on average 25 years,
that means one 25th of them die every year.
One 25th is 4%.
So when you see a death rate of 4%,
which can be expressed as 40 per hundred,
uh,
sorry.
Uh,
yeah,
40 per hundred or 444 per hundred or 40 per thousand.
Did I say 40%?
I meant 4%.
Sorry.
So,
so what,
what has happened over these thousands of years is that we managed to keep 1%
more people alive every year.
From here we're keeping,
the death rate is maybe 5% a year and the death rate here is maybe 4% a year.
So keep those numbers in mind as a primitive kind of minimum,
say using say the 25,
that 40 per thousand deaths and the population is going to be fairly stable,
so 40 per thousand births.
So that's that what was going on through most of human history.
Um,
now if you look at the actual numbers for Europe,
you see that Eastern Europe has,
uh,
this is the crude.
This is the death rate of not 40,
uh,
per thousand,
but 38 per thousand here.
Very,
very little bit better than the rate at which you really can't keep your
population alive anymore.
And this continues in eastern Europe till like 1860 to the civil war time.
This is the civil war in America.
UH,
Russia,
slow freeze.
It's surfs at about this time.
You've got a lot of the great Russian authors and the musicians are starting at
around that time.
So in eastern Europe,
the,
if,
if you measure standard of living by the death rate,
the death rate has improved very little over the 40 or 50,
not 50.
It's from thousands of years ago,
uh,
than the 40.
And then modern saying takes over and it falls very slowly.
Western Europe where the enlightenment a hit hit first,
uh,
is doing better this time.
And the line is sort of where a gang has con their line between East and Western
was basically where a gang has gone.
The Mongols occupied Europe,
uh,
that here in 1800 western Europe already has a death rate down to 28.
Remember I told you in the 17 hundreds,
the western foods come in and things start getting better.
So the death rate has been dropping at least all during the 17 hundreds.
And depending on what his story,
new read,
uh,
possibly before the 17 hundreds.
So Eastern Europe a hundred years later,
this is 1800,
this is 1890 eastern Europe is a hundred years behind western Europe more than a
hundred years,
but Europe has already,
western Europe has progressed somewhat and at this level the population is
increasing quite rapidly.
So during this period,
uh,
again,
population's increasing resources and production are increasing somewhat,
but the balance is not in favor of,
of standard of living.
So,
uh,
for instance,
food,
uh,
grain accounts for during this beard back 80% of the calories of the poor.
And even for the upper classes who had more meat and eggs and this kind of
stuff,
there's about 50%.
So you can look basically at a,
uh,
grain prices and wages in grain prices and tell how the people were living.
So in Strasbourg,
uh,
which is a very favorably situated,
fertile land on the Rhine,
just on the border between Germany and France.
Sometimes it's Germany and sometimes it's France.
Uh,
between 1400 and 1500,
for instance,
the amount of work needed to purchase a month or a month worth of wheat was in
the range of 60 to 80 hours.
This is so in,
in just before the reformation,
for instance,
60 to 80 hours by 15,
14 populated,
already increased.
It had risen to over a hundred hours and it doesn't,
and then it keeps going and it doesn't come back down to 100 hours until the
1880s.
So we're talking very,
very late.
The people are,
are not,
not living better.
Uh,
the wages of German workers,
again measured in grain because prices go up and down,
but how much grain can you buy with your work as the important number fell
roughly 50% between 1,516 50.
The percentage of males in Frankfurt in Germany with enough property to be
citizens fell from 75% in 17,
23 to 33%.
In 1811.
We're watching the population get impoverished massive unemployment in Germany
because wages to fall below subsistence levels,
especially in the 1840s and living standards in Germany showed no signs of
improvement before 1850 at the earliest.
So we're talking very modern times,
well into the industrial revolution
and things are not getting,
getting better.
You look at per capita income,
again,
population's growing,
the total national economy is growing,
but per capita you're not improving.
In England,
buying power started falling in the 15 hundreds and didn't recover to that level
until well into the 19th century in Paris.
Uh,
bread consumption did not increase per capita,
but did not increase between 1637 in 1854 pasture land didn't increase.
So the same amount of meat basically,
uh,
was produced with some improvement because of some calibrating a,
but now it was divided among more people.
And not only that,
but because potatoes had come in and potatoes could keep more people alive.
A lot of pasture land was taken away from pasture land and put into potatoes.
So basically,
uh,
meet became very scarce in European diets.
And again,
it decreased between the late Middle Ages in 1800.
It doesn't start recovering.
A forest did not increase,
in fact were cut down to have more land for agriculture.
So would become scarce for housing,
for heating,
uh,
for,
for heating houses.
We're building housing and so forth.
And so what happened during this period is that people standard of living was
going down.
They managed to stay alive.
They had to work harder and harder.
The hours that they work to get to maintain themselves alive,
uh,
kept increasing.
And yet they didn't make any progress.
And so we're talking about Ballpark,
a hundred years into the industrial revolution,
which we now that's what you're learning in high school.
The industrial I've learned in such a wonderful thing and an improved incomes
and the modern world is true to the industrial revolution.
But in actual fact,
the data shows that's really not the case.
That for about a hundred years,
the industrial revolution,
uh,
or making tremendous progress.
And then total national economies are growing very big.
The per capita income of all,
but the very upper classes doesn't really grow.
And so by this time,
of course my office is dead and,
but we know he's been laughing in his grave because he was very controversial.
Uh,
when he was alive,
he was very controversial and it really wasn't until the Irish potato famine
about which you've read and massive numbers of people died for a lack of
resources,
a bug guy killing the potatoes.
Then people said,
oh yeah,
maltose was right.
And then it kept going.
So,
uh,
his idea that progress could be just eaten up by population growth turns out to
be a characteristic of,
of many hundreds of years of European history and the rest of the world also.
Of course,
now an amazing thing happens in this to start changing the story.
And it happens in France.
I mean,
what happens?
The French,
which looked up until,
uh,
about 1800,
17,
50 or so,
look like any other population in Europe,
they had lots and lots of children,
but then they stopped having a lot of children.
It just came out of the blue a and what change?
The age of marriage didn't change a lot.
So that wasn't the cause of it.
The age at first,
first birth didn't cause a lot.
They weren't getting married then delaying childbirth that stayed about the
same.
The interval between babies didn't change very much.
So they were not,
uh,
using a much control within marriage.
Apparently once they got married and they just started popping out babies,
but they stopped having children at a young age.
So the age of land,
while the age at first birth doesn't change much.
The agent last birth changes by 10 years.
Families stop having children about 10 years earlier,
chopping out a very large fraction of their fertile years.
And this behavior is called stopping behavior.
And we see it all around the world eventually.
Well no one understood what was going on,
but they were horrified.
They knew,
they knew it was happening.
It was a,
people are well aware of it and there were quite horrified by it.
So any of you have watched television know that John Adams and his wife,
Abigail,
uh,
went to Europe about that time?
I think it was 1782.
And,
uh,
she especially was distressed at the French people's quote,
feeble commitment to family life,
exemplified by the French families only having three or four children rather
than the age or 10 that,
that you were supposed to have Americans at the time we're having eight or nine,
they were equally horrified.
This is again from the Adams,
they equally horrified by the French upper classes,
easy acceptance of adultery.
This they found was,
and this is John Adams speaking,
uh,
indication of the general moral and social disintegration.
He said the French are not a moral people.
So,
uh,
what happens is all this behavior which was wildly decried by everyone within a
century after France,
uh,
starts doing it,
all of Europe,
uh,
takes off and starts doing the same thing.
So here is
a graph of that.
This graph starts in a year and we'll talk about it later,
where fertility is already dropped by about 10%.
And here's France.
And this dates that when the fertility changes already been going on to the
1820s,
but it's actually started before that.
And then every other country in Europe starts dropping its fertility.
Within this period.
And it goes down by,
uh,
in,
in this space of time by by 30% and enormous change.
So even though France starts it early and everybody is horrified by it,
in fact,
everybody starts copying this.
Um,
and then this is Europe,
but in another century,
Asia and Latin America is follow suit.
So this is really a major change in what it means and how one lives life as,
as a human being.
So I've stressed or the biology of reproduction that there of course we have a
biological drive to,
to,
uh,
to keep having sex in there that produces children.
The culture or the culture or the religion presses upon people to keep their,
their birth rates up.
And this goes on for them.
Thousands and thousands of years of human history until the [inaudible],
the late 18 hundreds,
early for France,
and then all of a sudden all around Europe and then later in the world of this
very fundamental way of being a human,
uh,
changes.
So the big question in demography since this was noticed a long time ago,
is what caused this change?
Why did all of a sudden,
uh,
w w with no,
you know,
why did this,
all this all happened?
The people at the time were absolutely dumbfounded and dumbfounded,
especially that it should happen in France because at that time,
Francis,
at the height of its power,
it was the,
about the richest country in Europe.
It was the most powerful.
It was the most advanced and learning,
uh,
all the philosophic where there,
the encyclopedia was there,
you know,
it was the top of the world.
And,
you know,
why,
should of all places on earth,
the richest people on Earth Start,
stop,
uh,
having children.
And,
uh,
now that it wasn't important,
at that time,
it wasn't considered to be important.
But of course,
France has a totally Catholic country.
And so why should a Catholic country be the first one a and way ahead of
everyone else?
Uh,
to reduce its first first rate?
So historians have come up with all,
we don't know the answer,
but let me tell you that right out.
Uh,
but historians do have lots of answers,
uh,
for it.
And,
uh,
one of the reasons for the French fertility decline,
why in the moral and religious reassessments that occurred in the tumultuous
years of the French Revolution.
And for sure a moral,
uh,
re,
realignment was certainly taking place.
How many of you know the madame Bovary the novel and what's it a novel?
What's the central piece of the novel?
Yeah,
it's an adulterous affair,
right?
So here,
here's a woman,
a young married woman has a child and she has a perfectly nice husband who
adores her and is quite permissive.
You know,
she really has nothing objective to complain about,
but she considers him boring.
And so she takes an exciting lover or series of,
of lovers.
And so I'm not going to give away the plot,
but the book was taken as a justification for having extra marital affairs.
Now that's okay for men and women has been okay for Matt,
but here's a woman,
him trusting me,
this,
this flow.
Baird justifying a woman's having,
uh,
an extra metal fair,
not because the husband was beating her or anything.
It's perfectly decent guy.
So that was considered terrible.
And,
uh,
he was promptly arrested and prosecuted by the government for code of fronting
religious morality.
And of course that was very good for sales of the book.
So everybody read that book,
including a lot of us still at Yale.
So,
uh,
people were,
the rest of Europe are well aware of the French lead in this and an English
speaking countries.
France was blamed for the problem and especially French novels.
And they were,
they were,
they were corrupting a,
our people.
They were fomenting extramarital liaisons and by implication,
the use of contraception.
But this spreads very rapidly.
So who knows the plot of Anna Karenina,
an adulterous affair,
right.
And again,
her husband wasn't quite as nice as,
as,
as Bovary.
Uh,
he was kind of a stiff guy,
but he wasn't beating her.
And you know,
he wasn't really a bad guy.
She goes off and has a wild affair.
And that Warren piece in endocrine hormone and the brothers Karamazov,
you know,
one of the three greatest Russian novels are exactly on this same mode as full
Bayer.
And they're all,
uh,
really talking about this change in attitude toward fertility and sexuality that
was overcoming Europe at this time.
So much later,
not that much later after the European fertility transition was over,
which only lasts till about 1930 by nine it starts in 1870.
You'll see these dates,
the fertility drops out except for France starts in about 18,
17 is all over by 1930.
And social scientists start thinking about this fertility rob,
but not in moralistic terms anymore,
not how it was ruining our morals,
but in terms of sort of quantifiable explanations.
And so the major,
you know,
again,
and asking this,
which is probably the most important question in all the social sciences,
you know,
most the most important change in how it is to be a human and
what is the cause of this.
So they did a very massive project and we'll have a guest speaker who is one of
the main,
uh,
people in this Michael title mound that they,
they,
they set up what they call an office of population research and they divvy to
every graduate student got a different country in Europe and he went into that
country and looked at all the provincial records and dug out everything they
could find.
And they got massive statistics on everything they could figure out about every
province in Europe and not only western Europe,
but all the way across Europe into Russia.
And so it was the most,
probably the most massive social science,
uh,
investigation that that ever took place.
And,
uh,
what had come up by that time already was kind of a Schema of what's what we now
called the demographic transition.
So I've shown you how the death rate,
there's,
there's no particular dates.
This is sort of very generalized kind of idea that the death rate,
the first thing that happens at home is that the death rate falls,
right.
And then at some time later,
the birth rate falls.
And I lastly this,
early on I just grabbed it,
dropping the death rate and now we see that sometime later the birth rate
happens.
Well,
what happens in between is this population growth.
In old times,
the birth rate was very high in the death rate was very high,
but they're pretty,
nearly matched.
The little bit of different.
So population does grow,
but it grows very slowly.
When it's all over,
the birth rate is low and the death rate is low.
Again,
there's a little difference in population grows slowly or nowadays,
and a lot of Europe,
the birth rate goes below the death rate and population decreases somewhat
slowly button.
There's no super rapid change here.
There's no big rapid change here,
but in between the death and the death rate falls and the time and the birth
rate falls,
all of this is population growth because the birth rate is above the death rate.
So this is the period of the population explosions and the first of these
populations versions was in Europe,
not in the poor countries,
not in the developing world,
but in the richest part of the world at that time.
Which was huge was Europe.
The same Schema is supposed to apply uh,
later on.
So this is uh,
as an empirical generalization medium that some countries fit this.
Nobody is terribly far from this,
that the birth rate and the death rate always go down in some relationship to
each other.
But the question which arises is,
is it,
is the correlation good enough that the death rate actually co the dropping the
death rate actually causes the drop in the birth rate.
And the theory runs in a rather obvious way that parents know how many children
they want.
They know roughly how many children and they can keep alive,
how much farm land they have to give them to inherit,
how many they need to take care of them in their old,
old age when the death rate is very high and not only high but very variable.
I showed you last time in Sweden though,
the death rate going up and down when the death rate is high in variable,
you don't know if you have a lot of children,
you don't know how many are going to survive.
So you need not only as many children's you want and taking into account the
death rate,
but in taking into account the variability of the death rate,
what if an epidemic comes through when my kids are young?
So you have to have a lot of children,
uh,
in order to ensure that in your old age you'll have some to take care of you
as the death rate falls people gradually real.
The I,
the theory is that people gradually realize this and they reduced their
fertility because they don't need to to bear so many children in order to have
so many left at the end because the children,
they start getting confidence that the children are not going to die.
So this is a lovely theory.
And how many of you have have heard that?
Some version of that?
Yeah.
No,
it's one of the,
you'll see it as about 10 standard versions,
theories about why fertility falls.
This is number one,
that,
that it's the fall in the death rate causes the fall in the birth rate.
So now we're going to,
this is look and see how accurate that this is.
So this is uh,
Norway actually and here is the death rate.
This black line from Norway and it starts falling from about,
uh,
middle of the 17 hundreds and pretty continuous fall during all this time right
here is the birth rate pretty constant across here.
And then it finally starts falling,
uh,
in its 1900,
I think.
So there's a long a time period between when the birth rate starts falling and
when the,
sorry,
when the death rate starts falling and when the birth rate starts flowing.
The difference between those coats is,
is this line here that all of this is population growth.
And in this period here where the death rate is quite a ways down,
but the birth rate hasn't responded very much yet.
The Norwegian population grows by this,
this amount.
So that standard,
that's the way it's supposed to work.
That's the way the scheme of shows it working.
But now you're look at England and England and Wales
and you don't get this picture.
Here is a fertility,
the gray thing and fertility starts dropping.
As I said,
around 1870,
maybe 80.
This shows a little bit after 1875 or so,
and then it drops rather continuously.
This is fertility.
Infant mortality,
which is good measure of total mortality doesn't really start dropping.
It's pretty constant ups and downs until like 19,
1905 or something like that.
And it only starts going down.
So here it's the reverse situation that now you have fertility falling first and
mortality falling later.
And you can make a causal explanation for this,
that well,
when people are having lots and lots of kids,
they can't take care of them.
They don't have enough food,
they don't have enough this,
that and the other thing.
So there's very high death rate among the children,
but,
uh,
if you dropped your fertility,
you have more resources for each child.
And that's actually as compelling,
uh,
an explanation ne without,
in the absence of data as,
as the reverse explanation.
And,
uh,
if you look,
across many,
many countries,
which the Princeton project did,
uh,
this is,
the drop in the mortality rate,
this graph,
and this is the drop in the fertility rate.
And this is the years,
same year starts in 1825 this 1975 1975 so this is the period when the change
was happening and for fertility here,
this period is when birth rate has already come down by about 10% you'll see
that some kind of a threshold and when it's down then by something like 30% I
think it ends and mortality has also its limits.
This is the period when mortality is falling in Norway and Denmark and Sweden
and England and Wales and so forth and all.
You have to look at the order of these things as if Tonia for fertility.
France is the first one by a long shot.
It starts,
they put it in the early 18 hundreds it's down by 10% already and it's all over
by 1900 or so France way ahead in time of anybody else.
Now you look at the mortality and you say,
well,
where is France?
It's not no,
right?
It's not.
Their market's not Sweden.
Ooh,
where are,
where's France?
Uh,
what do I even see?
France?
Yeah,
there it is.
It's way in the middle of the pack.
Oh,
that doesn't fit the theory.
And he go the other way.
Norway is the first one to drop.
It's mortality rate.
And where is Norway more or less than the middle of the pack when you look at
fertility.
So these two things don't correlate as nicely.
Again,
this is the Princeton project don't correlate as nicely as the theory,
uh,
would have us do.
And the end result of all these graduate students studying the relationship
between mortality and fertility was the,
that we don't know what's going on because we saw everything under the sun.
There's no very strong correlation
and,
but they were very smart and they tried all kinds of things.
And another way you can look at it is to see at what level of uh,
mortality may be looking at.
Years is not the right thing,
but the level of mortality.
So they looked at infant mortality levels,
uh,
at the time when the fertility dropped.
And what you have is in France,
the infant mortality is still very high.
You know,
just infants,
it's not total mortality in window almost 300 here.
When France strops starts dropping its fertility,
sometime this,
they puts it something that somewhere in the late 17,
hundreds of fertility started dropping and the,
the informer tower was still very high.
And then you can go around the world,
all different kinds of places.
Japan,
160,
Norway a hundred,
that it doesn't seem to be any kind of commonality here in what the infant
mortality actually was when fertility,
uh,
drops.
And remember the 400 is sort of the,
the,
the primitive level.
And actually when you go into Asia,
you can see that in places like Taiwan,
uh,
and uh,
Mexico on macro doesn't,
they'd moved from Asia that at Mexico and Taiwan,
the mortality was a 35,
uh,
a hundred,
was 35 so very close to the,
to the primitive level where you can just keep your society going and yet
fertility starts dropping.
So basically you see the whole,
the whole range,
the whole range is something like 35 or 40,
and you don't keep your society live less than that.
And Modern Japan will be at this time be about five.
And you see that and the range is what you actually see is this whole range
anywhere in that range of what a mortality levels people actually achieve can be
the range at which,
uh,
fertility starts to fall.
So there's no real conclusion possible.
Okay.
What's explanation number two?
That you all have heard?
Economic Development,
right?
How many have heard that explanation?
Oh,
not so many.
That's very stand.
The whole Reagan Reagan on the whole Reagan policy was,
and for a lot of lot of the world was that,
forget about family planning and pushing that,
that economic development is what reduces fertility.
So that's a very good theory also.
And uh,
we can look at it and wow,
the data looks pretty good down here is per capita income in each of these is a
separate country here.
And Wow,
for every country,
as per capita income goes up,
fertility comes down.
It can come down a fairly straight line or can do some wiggles and jiggles.
But basically as per capita income goes up,
uh,
fertility goes down.
You like that theory,
but there's some problems with it.
So how much money does it take,
uh,
to keep people out of bed basically?
Well,
the French start dropping their fertility when their per capita income is
something like 180.
Uh,
this is in a
converted to basically dollars $180 a year,
50 cents a day.
Back then there was more money than now.
Keeps,
keeps the Frenchmen out of bed.
Now anybody who of Italian extraction will be very proud to realize that it
takes the Italians oh,
twice as much.
360 or something to keep them.
But so we have now scientifically and quantitatively proven that Italians like
definitely sexy and French people.
Right.
And then you go along,
he has the Germans a little bit stolid here.
And of course who we had exactly the opposite of what we presume that,
you know,
the English is supposed to be sold straight,
that they don't do it at all.
And yet in order to keep the British out of bed,
you have to really pay them an awful lot.
They have to be somewhere between 700 and $800 in income.
So there doesn't seem to be any particular number of income and it has a huge
range,
uh,
that is required before people drop their fertility.
And when you think about it a little,
uh,
more,
this whole way of looking at it is,
is not a very convincing because here's per capita income,
but we're talking about the time of industrialization and after fertility starts
dropping,
so once fertility starts dropping,
per capita income does start rising.
That's sort of the most important take home message for day.
So I'll say it before,
before time runs out,
that the industrial revolution by itself did really improve the standard of
living of people up until about 1870.
It was tremendous increase in productivity,
tremendous increase in population.
They cancel each other out.
And for the average working person in the standard of living does not rise.
Starting roughly 1870 people drop their fertility rates and the standard of
living starts rising.
And we see it starts rising all along here.
So if you take any dates from 1870 till today,
our til a few months ago anyway,
uh,
per capita income is rising everywhere in Europe.
At different rates,
but everywhere in Europe.
So anything is progressing in everything that you can measure about Europe,
changes in what we call monotonic.
And in a single drink,
education goes up,
urbanization goes up,
the number of the year a go goes up,
everything women's education goes up,
women's education goes up,
anything that you can think of goes up and fertility goes down.
So when you make graphs like that,
anything that you put on this axis is going up this,
this handy per capita income.
It could be education,
industrialization,
urbanization,
and fertility is falling during this period.
So any two variables that you put together will give you similar graph to this
and it tells you absolutely nothing except the only thing you can think of that,
well,
there is no particular level of income which causes people to drop.
When you get into the developing worlds,
the levels of way,
way below,
uh,
they're,
they're out,
they're out here and they start dropping their,
their fertility levels.
So they repeated this over and over again for all kinds of hypotheses.
Um,
and they always got the same kind of answer that nothing really correlated very
well.
Literacy is another answer that when people start getting more worldly because
they can read.
And fertility began to fall.
One literacy rates were very low in France,
in Bulgaria and Hungary,
but literacy was already very high in England and Wales when its fertility fell,
urbanization,
uh,
the British fertility decline when it began in Britain in 1870,
72% of the British were ready in what are called conurbations in urban urban
settings,
but in France,
and they started a hundred years earlier,
uh,
very,
low level.
So I want to continue this,
but that Princeton project was a massive,
massive study of all the every socioeconomic variable that you can think of.
All the theories.
Well,
the 10 theories that you hear around and,
and from your friends and think yourself,
none of them really worked out as something you could really nail to fertility
drops because infant mortality drops or income goes,
opera education goes up or any of these sorts of things.
So next time we will continue and,
uh,
tell you at least what the Princeton people thought was the real cards.